estamos reportando desde una marcha de
protesta que han salido los diferentes
colectivos pero peruanos que han venido
del interior del país y otros sindicatos
que se han sumado a esta protesta Ellos
están rechazando la dilación que está
tomando el congreso para la aprobación
de la Reforma por el adelanto de
elecciones el congresista Jaime quito
quien es el líder en minoría de la
izquierda que ha presentado este
proyecto Está tratando de reunir los
votos pero Fuentes del parlamento nos
señalan que con las justas podría reunir
alrededor de 45 votos y no los 87 que
son los necesarios para aprobar la
reforma Cuál es el principal descollo es
que se incluya el referéndum de consulta
para una asamblea Constituyente la
bancada derecha no van a dejar que esto
proceda diversos representantes de esta
marcha nos han dicho que hay intereses
supuestamente de grupos económicos de
poder que no quieren que el congreso que
por la derecha de este país cambie la
Constitución actual que privilegia a una
política neoliberal que favorece la
explotación de recursos naturales en
desmuedro de los territorios de los
pueblos originarios de este país
Francisco y hoy boluarte reiteró que no
va a renunciar Por más que el congreso
no apoye el adelanto de las elecciones
Qué reacción ha tenido la presidenta
sobre la demora en el congreso para
aprobar este proyecto
bueno la presidenta boluarte ha sido muy
enfática le ha dado un claro mensaje al
congreso dejémonos de intereses
particulares que son intereses políticos
intereses partidarios y vayamos todos
juntos a aprobar una reforma que sea por
el bien del país en estos momentos en
que Perú se encuentra sumido en una
crisis política y social la mandataria
le ha dicho a los peruanos hay que
terminar con la confrontación y la
polarización y por eso les ha pedido al
congreso que prioricen esta reforma la
mandataria por otro lado también le ha
hecho un mensaje en alusión al
presidente Pedro Castillo ha manifestado
que su gobierno no va a caber ante la
violencia y el radicalismo de las
protestas que según la mandataria
peruana estarían dirigidas desde la
cárcel de barbadío donde se encuentra
detenido el expresidente Pedro Castillo
así las cosas vamos a ver si esta
jornada va a culminar esta noche o
quizás se suspenda han sido las otras
reuniones que ha tenido el parlamento
por el momento las cosas están
estancadas y tal como dicen los
analistas políticos en los congresistas
están haciendo todo lo posible por
dilatar este proceso Mientras tanto las
protestas y los bloqueos de carreteras
continúan en el interior del